BUT FIRST, WITHOUT A TRACE,
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
THE FOURTH OF JULY IS STILL SIX
WEEKS AWAY, GIVEN THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE TODAY, A REMINDER
OF WHY WE CELEBRATE.
>> WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT, THAT ALL MEN ARE
CREATED EQUAL.
THAT THEY ARE ENDOWED BY THEIR
CREATOR WITH CERTAIN INALIENABLE
RIGHTS, AMONG THESE ARE LIFE,
LIBERTY, AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
>> Laura: EARLIER TODAY A GOOD
FRIEND OF MINE AND I WERE
TALKING ABOUT HOW SURPRISING IT
WAS THAT SO MANY AMERICANS WERE
WILLING TO GIVE UP THERE IN A
INALIENABLE RIGHT FOR A
GOVERNMENT PROMISE OF SAFETY.
BASIC LIBERTY, THE RIGHT TO
WORK, TRAVEL, WORSHIP, FREE
SPEECH, TO PETITION THE
GOVERNMENT, TO ASSEMBLE WITH
OTHERS.
THEY ALL WERE COMPLETELY
SIDELINED OR PARTIALLY SIDELINED
DURING THE COVID-19 SHUT DOWN.
OFFICIALS ASSURED US THAT
RESTRICTIONS WOULD BE
SHORT-LIVED, AND ONLY BE IN
PLACE UNTIL WE FLATTEN THE
CURVE.
BUT EVEN AFTER WE DID THAT AND
HOSPITALS THANKFULLY WERE NOT
OVERRUN, BLUE STATE GOVERNORS
BEGAN PILING ON NEW CONDITIONS
IN ORDER FOR STATES TO BE FULLY
REOPENED AGAIN.
COMPLICATED REQUIREMENTS IN THE
NEW YORK 51 PAGE REOPENING
DOCUMENT, MICHIGAN, ILLINOIS,
WASHINGTON STATE SEEM HELL-BENT
ON KEEPING PEOPLE IMMOBILE AND
SCARED AS LONG AS POSSIBLE AND
NOW THEY FOUND A NEW EXCUSE FOR
DELAYING COME OF THE NEED FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
SO-CALLED CONTACT TRACERS.
>> THE POINT OF THIS IS TO
CREATE A CORE OF TRAINED FOLKS
WHO ARE READY AND ABLE AND HAVE
THE SKILLS WE NEED THEM TO HAVE
TO HELP USHER US ALL THROUGH THE
NEW ENVIRONMENT TO.
>> I KNOW A LOT OF YOU DON’T
ANSWER THE PHONE WHEN YOU SEE AN
UNKNOWN CALLER, BUT I IMPLORE
YOU, TO ANSWER THAT CALL.
>> WE WANT TO GROW OUR VOLUNTARY
CONTACT TRACING SO WE CAN
FURTHER CONTROL AND REDUCE THE
RATE OF SPREAD OF COVID-19 AND
THE STOP OUTBREAKS IN THEIR
TRACKS.
>> Laura: YEAH, I TRUST HIM.
WHAT TSA WAS TO THE POST 9/11
ERA, CONTACT TRACING IS TO THE
COVID ERA, IT’S ALL FOR OUR OWN
GOOD AND PROTECTION, THAT’S WHAT
THEY SAY.
IT SEEMS FINE AT FIRST, AND
UNTIL MAYBE WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
TSA, AN AGENT’S HANDS GETS A
LITTLE TOO CLOSE TO YOUR PRIVATE
PARTS DURING A RANDOM SCREENING
AND THEN THEY THROW AWAY YOUR
FAVORITE MOISTURIZER BECAUSE
IT’S TOO MANY OUNCES.
AT LEAST HER INTERACTION WITH
THE TSA AGENT IS BRIEF AND
LIMITED TO ONLY WHEN YOU FLY.
YOUR INTERACTION WITH A COVID
TRACER COULD LAST FOR WEEKS IF
NOT LONGER.
ACCORDING TO THE AP, THE
PRACTICE OF SO-CALLED CONTACT
TRACING REQUIRES A HYBRID JOB OF
INTERROGATOR, THERAPIST, AND
NURSE, AS THEY TRY TO COAX
NERVOUS PEOPLE TO BE HONEST.
THE GOAL, TO CREATE A ROAD MAP
OF EVERYWHERE INFECTED PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN AND WHO THEY’VE BEEN
AROUND.
THAT’S A HEAVY LIFT.
HOW MANY OF THESE TRACERS WILL
WE NEED?
>> HEALTH INVESTIGATOR
McKENZIE BRAY FOLLOWED THIS
PATH THAT SHE KNOWS TOO WELL.
>> I’M FOLLOWING UP ON YOUR TEST
RESULTS.
>> HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
VOLUNTEERS ARE WORKING CONTACT
TRACERS, SOME HEALTH OFFICIALS
ESTIMATE THAT AS MANY AS 300,000
CONTACT TRACERS WILL BE NEEDED
IN THE COUNTRY TO EFFECTIVELY
MITIGATE THE SPREAD.
>> Laura: ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
300,000?
THIS KIND OF REMINDS ME OF THE
TSA, IF THE EXPERTS GET THEIR
WAY, THERE WILL BE SIX TIMES
MORE CONTACT TRACERS THEN TSA
AGENTS.
INSTEAD OF RUMMAGING THROUGH
YOUR LUGGAGE, THESE CONTACT
TRACERS WILL BE PRYING INTO THE
MOST INTIMATE DETAILS OF YOUR
LIFE.
IF YOU’RE FOUND TO HAVE BEEN IN
THE ORBIT OF SOMEONE WHO TESTED
POSITIVE FOR THE VIRUS, THEY
COULD MONITOR YOUR WHEREABOUTS
CONTINUOUSLY UNTIL THEY
DETERMINE YOUR NO LONGER A
DANGER TO OTHERS.
RIGHT NOW IT MAY BE ONLY FOR 14
DAYS OR SO BUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THE NEXT EXPERT TELLS US
SOMETHING DIFFERENT?
MAY BE NEXT WEEK?
WHAT ABOUT YOUR MEDICAL
INFORMATION, VERY PERSONAL TO
YOU?
ACCORDING TO THE TRACER TRAINING
PROGRAM RUN BY JOHNS HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY THAT WE HAD A
PRODUCER ACTUALLY SIGN UP FOR
TODAY, IT’S REQUIRED FOR TRACERS
HIRED IN NEW YORK.
MEDICAL INFORMATION WILL BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL, THEY SAY, THOUGH
PERHAPS NOT ALL OF IT.
THIS IS HOW ONE SLIDE IN THAT
TRAINING PROGRAM PUTS IT.
THAT MEDICAL INFORMATION CANNOT
BE SHARED WITH ANYONE ELSE
UNLESS YOU AGREE WITH THAT,
UNLESS YOUR COVID-19 TEST
RESULTS CAN BE SHARED TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WHY IS THAT?
ACCORDING TO JOHNS HOPKINS,
CONTRACT TRACING PROGRAMS ARE A
PUBLIC GOOD.
THEY CAN REDUCE ILLNESS AND
DEATH FROM COVID-19.
A PUBLIC GOOD.
IT SOUNDS FINE, REASONABLE.
BUT I THOUGHT IN A
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY, THE
PEOPLE GET TO DETERMINE WHAT IS
IN THE "PUBLIC GOOD" NOT
UNACCOUNTABLE EXPERTS AT A
UNIVERSITY THAT RECEIVES
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN GRANT
MONEY FROM BILLIONAIRES IN
CORPORATE FOUNDATIONS.
GIVEN YOU THE ENORMITY OF THE
FEDERAL AND STATE EXPENDITURES
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE, IT’S
AMAZING HOW LITTLE DEBATE THERE
HAS BEEN ABOUT THE RISK TO
PERSONAL PRIVACY.
I’M TELLING YOU, THERE ARE
ALWAYS GOING TO BE PLENTY OF
REASONS CITED BY GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRATS OR UNELECTED
TECHNOCRATS TO JUSTIFY TAKING
YOUR FREEDOMS AWAY.
THEY’LL CITE SCARY THINGS LIKE
GUN VIOLENCE, CLIMATE CHANGE,
AND NOW OF COURSE COVID OR MAYBE
THE NEXT VIRUS.
THEY WILL USE OUR FEAR OR MAYBE
EXCUSE STATISTICS OR A BAD MODEL
TO MANIPULATE THE PUBLIC
PERCEPTION.
THEY WILL FIND EXPERTS WHO
INSIST THAT THEY HARM TO
PERSONAL PRIVACY IS MINIMAL AND
ANY TRADE-OFF IS WORTH IT.
THEY’LL PROMISE THEIR ACTIONS
WILL BE TEMPORARY AND NARROWLY
TAILORED TO.
INVARIABLY THESE NEW PROGRAMS,
LIKE WHAT WE SAW AFTER 9/11,
WILL BECOME A PERMANENT FIXTURES
IN AMERICAN LIFE AND END UP
EXPANDING FAR BEYOND THE
PROMISED GOALS.
I THINK BACK TO THE CREATION OF
THE FISA COURT, THE PATRIOT ACT,
JUST TO NAME A FEW.
THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW, BAD
ACTORS USE THEM AS WEAPONS
AGAINST INNOCENT PEOPLE, AND
THEY ALMOST MANAGED TO UNDO A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THE GOVERNMENT CAN USE A VARIETY
OF TOOLS TO ENFORCE ITS NEW
NORMAL, USING SELF-ASSESSMENT
TOOLS IS THE LEAST CONCERNING I
THINK FROM A PERSONAL PRIVACY
STANDPOINT.
BUT THEN THERE ARE THESE
LOCATION DEVICES USING A VARIETY
OF TECHNOLOGICAL TOOLS TO
MONITOR YOU.
YESTERDAY, GOOGLE AND APPLE
UNVEILED A PHONE APP THAT LETS
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU’VE BEEN
EXPOSED TO SOMEONE WHO’S COVID
THE POSITIVE PERIOD OF 22
COUNTRIES HAVE ALREADY SIGNED ON
TO USE THE APP.
NOW THE TECH GIANTS DID CRAFT
THIS APP WITH USER PRIVACY IN
MIND, WILL GIVE THEM THUMBS UP
FOR THAT BUT ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" THE
ENTIRE PURPOSE OF THE APP IS TO
"HELP PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
TRACK CONTACT BETWEEN
STRANGERS."
PERSONALLY, I TAKE WHATEVER
PRIVACY PROMISES THAT THOSE AT
THESE COMPANIES ARE MAKING WITH
A GRAIN OF SALT.
THE FACT IS, TRACKING TECHNOLOGY
CAN HAVE A TERRIBLE CHILLING
EFFECT ON INDIVIDUAL FREEDOM AND
EXPRESSION.
THE SUPREME COURT NOTED THIS A
FEW YEARS AGO AND IT’S A RULING
TO ENFORCE LOCATION DATA
PROTECTION.
THE COURT IN CARPENTER VERSUS
UNITED STATES SAID DETAILED
TRAVEL INFORMATION PROVIDES AN
INTIMATE DETAIL INTO A PERSON’S
LIFE, REVEALING NOT ONLY
PARTICULAR MOVEMENTS BUT THROUGH
THEM, HIS FAMILIAL, POLITICAL,
PROFESSIONAL, RELIGIOUS, AND
ASSOCIATIONS.
REMEMBER THOSE SEEMINGLY HELPFUL
COVID TRACKING APPS ARE
THEMSELVES WINDOWS INTO YOUR
LIFE.
A SERVICE CAN BE HACKED, DATA
STOLEN, AND GENERALLY THE DATA
IS AVAILABLE TO ANYONE FOR THEFT
OR PURCHASE.
ADVERTISERS, CYBER CRIMINALS,
EVEN POLITICAL ADVERSARIES, AND
SO ON.
SO CAN THE GOVERNMENT, FEDERAL,
STATE REALLY ENSURE THAT OUR
DATA NOT BE ACCESSIBLE TO ANY OF
THE ABOVE?
OF COURSE THE ANSWER IS NO.
IT WOULD BE NAIVE TO THINK
OTHERWISE.
THEY COULD PERHAPS MANDATE THAT
THE HEALTH INFORMATION ONLY BE
AVAILABLE TO HEALTH AUTHORITIES.
BUT GIVEN HOW WRONG IS SO MANY
OF THEIR HEALTH EXPERTS HAVE
BEEN LATELY, YOU REALLY CAN’T
BLAME AMERICANS WHO HAVE SEVERE
RESERVATIONS ABOUT TRUSTING THEM
WITH THEIR PRIVATE MEDICAL
INFORMATION.
BACK TO OUR DECLARATION.
OUR FRAMERS WERE REALLY SMART.
THOMAS JEFFERSON USED THAT WORD
IN ALIENABLE TO DESCRIBE OUR
RIGHTS FOR A REASON, AMERICANS
ARE BORN FREE.
WE DON’T GET OUR RIGHTS FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE GOVERNMENT
CAN NEVER TAKE THEM AWAY.
THE GOVERNMENT MAY SOMETIMES
FORCE US TO MAKE SACRIFICES, BUT
NOT INDEFINITELY, AND NOT
WITHOUT A SERIOUS DEBATE OVER
WHAT IS IN FACT ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY TO PRESERVE THE LIVES